move there for me and let's get a bit  more now on al Shabab these are the  latest pictures one of the latest still  photographs taken from the CCTV cameras  in the shopping centre I would show  clearly their show well one of the  terrorists at least carrying some kind  of automatic weapon and man behind in  there Tim Marshall our foreign affairs  editor is with me here and Tim these  these are the kind of images I mean  chilling reminders of places like Mumbai  that was the first thing I thought and  as I saw that I thought I was reminded  of the Mumbai Massacre another line  that's just dropped on that news wires  is that the Kenyan authorities say that  they've defeat defused some explosive  devices inside the shopping centre if  that is the case they'll be going very  very slowly looking for more and that  will slow down the operation as well